sony's game against alien cowboys are
usa
it
seems
okay i had to count on robots here
so the
lineup alright he makes a lot of five
but that's probably not going to be
used directly either
3 is aimed at springer 6 c
545 and
i think advantages  to achieve on the structure
where structure is still
understated
and black now loses the
hadamarer
well
if you are here as a human being
it is clearly better here so that the seven
is not possible because of runners at 5
so
now simply
new ones are imposed yes
after two  back so
he will try to
make the artificial oasis here
you can somehow use it directly
and the funnel well
at most with but violence
as well as 4
how much cb
yes
to cbc b to b 8 comes in time yes probably probably
you
cannot use that and then  let's do a
normal position and think that we
have more speed or something like that because of the
weird king to
do it to 7
knights at 5 doesn't seem to be a threat
and
maybe monkeys
I was definitely slow as usual
well
there is quality around these these
pawns  now to capture
good then certainly do
so the
question is are we right here now
plays not only for the first time at
this
pace with
he says he then has a trick okay but i
also like a star so ok g2
is not the end of the world yet
if he takes it,
which of course you watch out for, but how
about dame b5
with the edf ag
if it goes in here for 48 years
if sophia got six gf1 and
got this build here in the meantime
so
good
if we go back now or
insist on the idea here
I could do with that, yes, come on,
I have to go a bit faster,
how was that, just keep going, after all,
you are ultimately
a quality more than first,
now, for sure, the
feeder b 504, maybe now I want to
go to b 4,
into the runner here  sometimes
to bother
so thomann 7 we also like to take
with us at speed
to
so
if he now the runners for example
I do g4 with it and then that should
actually be so that
they don't dodge a field we
now I think it puts around
1.1
followers  catch he has
i think only 4 and 3 each is then caught
i think he hasn’t served here now
would have then here in chess
okay okay
from the bouquet
so he wants to miss
this handling is fine with me because
the rook is also tinted  is
abandoned here today after the cloud, it's
very simple because even the
fragmented farmers don't mind the
two against one I'm free to build and have
patience